Hallo!
Hallo Janusz, schön, dich zu sehen.
Hallo Cari.
Und hallo liebe Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer.
Schön, euch zu sehen!
Wir begrüßen euch heute live auf YouTube
und auf Facebook.
Wir hoffen, dass es euch gut geht und wir
sind heute live.
Wir haben gleich einiges Programm vorbereitet
und ihr könnt heute auch mit uns schreiben.
Es gibt nämlich einen Chat auf YouTube und
auf Facebook und dort könnt ihr uns mal einen
Kommentar schreiben und vielleicht lesen wir
dann euren Kommentar hier vor oder beantworten
auch eure Fragen.
Janusz, was ist das Thema unseres heutigen
Livestreams?
Äh, das weiß ich nicht ganz.
Das Thema ist: Manuel geht spazieren und berichtet
uns von dem, was er sieht.
Wir sind heute wieder live in Berlin, wir
setzen unser populäres Straßenformat fort.
Und wir schalten jetzt mal ganz direkt zu
unserem rasenden Reporter Manuel Salmann.
Manuel, wo bist du gerade?
Hallo Leute!
Ich stehe auf der Marshall-Brücke in Berlin.
Hinter mir seht ihr die Spree und den Reichstag
und den Sonnenuntergang.
Und heute mit dabei ist auch Lorenz, ich habe
die Hände frei zum ersten Mal, denn Lorenz
unterstützt uns an der Kamera und ich bin
total aufgeregt.
Wahnsinn!
Manuel, du bist jetzt gerade live in Berlin,
kann man dich dort treffen?
Klar!
Also, wenn man Glück hat oder Pech, je nach
Sichtweise, dann könnt ihr mich jetzt die
nächsten 30 bis 40 Minuten hier in dieser
Gegend treffen, ja.
Okay.
Also wenn ihr in der Nähe wohnt, fahrt jetzt
schnell zum Brandenburger Tor, dort werdet
ihr Manuel sehen.
Manuel, was wirst du uns heute zeigen?
Wir machen uns jetzt auf den Weg.
Also hier habt ihr schon mal den Bundestag
bzw. den Reichstag, so heißt ja das Gebäude,
von hinten gesehen.
Und wir gehen jetzt mal außenrum, schauen
uns das berühmte Brandenburger Tor an und
ein paar andere Orte hier des Regierungsviertels.
Als Erstes würde ich euch vielleicht noch
mal kurz das ARD Hauptstadtstudio zeigen,
dort sieht man oft abends in der Tagesschau,
wenn die Polit-Journalisten, die, die über
die Berliner Politik berichten, die stehen
dann da oben im Fenster und ja, machen ihren
Bericht.
Wahnsinn.
Während ihr losgeht, möchte ich mal vorlesen,
wo unsere Zuschauer heute herkommen.
Sie kommen aus Brasilien, aus den Vereinigten
Arabischen Emiraten, aus Marokko, aus Ägypten,
aus Mexiko, aus Leipzig, aus Berlin.
Nee, "ich liebe Berlin".
Aus Algerien, aus Brasilien, aus Bayern, aus
Karlsruhe.
Schreibt uns gerne, wo ihr herkommt, wir freuen
uns, dass ihr live zuguckt.
Indien, Peking, Frankreich, Chile, Texas,
Schweiz.
Wow.
Thailand.
Die ganze Welt guckt zu, Manuel, wie du durch
Berlin läufst.
Mach mich nicht nervös, Cari.
Wie schön!
Libanon, Serbien, Jordanien.
Toll.
Es geht weiter: Türkei, England.
Manuel, du läufst jetzt in welche Richtung?
Ja, wir laufen jetzt Richtung… also erst
mal Richtung Hotel Adlon, das ist ein sehr
bekanntes Hotel.
- Was ist das?
Das heißt doch so, oder?
(Ja.)
Ist das das Hotel Adlon?
Genau, das ist ein Hotel direkt am Brandenburger
Tor, da haben schon viele sehr berühmte und
wichtige Menschen übernachtet.
Und auf dem Weg dahin kommen wir jetzt gleich
an der französischen Botschaft vorbei, die
britische Botschaft sehe ich auch schon von
hier, während wir hier an der roten Ampel
warten.
Und dann geht es auch schon weiter zum Brandenburger
Tor.
Manuel, du bist heute in diplomatischer Mission
unterwegs im Regierungsviertel in Berlin.
Vorsicht.
Du hast auch… Oh!
Ist gefährlich hier, hier kommt der Bus 100.
Mit dem kann man auch eine schöne Stadtrundfahrt
machen, für den günstigen Preis von drei
Euro sieht man viele tolle Orte in Berlin.
Das ist schön.
Manuel, du hast gerade schon einen Staatsbesuch
gesehen, das heißt, du hast eine, viele schwarze
Autos mit Polizei gesehen, eine sogenannte
Wagenkolonne.
Was… was hast du da gesehen?
Erzähl uns.
Ja, das war… Kurz, bevor wir hier live gegangen
sind, kam hier so eine ganze Kolonne von Autos
mit Polizei-Motorrädern vorbei.
Und wenn ich das richtig gesehen habe aus
der Ferne, war eine österreichische Flagge
an der Limousine, also das war eventuell ein
Staatsbesuch aus Österreich.
So, Manuel, ich habe das schon recherchiert.
Und zwar ist das tatsächlich die Ministerpräsidentin
von Lettland gewesen.
Oh, na.
Denn…
Knapp.
Knapp vorbei.
Lettland hat auch eine ähnliche Fahne, also,
rot-weiß, und ich bin jetzt hier gerade in
Angela Merkels privatem Terminkalender, der
ist nämlich live, öffentlich unter "bundeskanzlerin.de".
Und dort kann ich sehen, was Angela Merkel
heute geplant hat, wenn du… Gehst du gleich
noch zu Angela Merkel?
Gehst du da vorbei?
Das würde ich doch sagen, oder?
Wir schauen mal, was sie so macht in ihren
letzten Tagen im Amt.
Richtig.
Angela Merkel ist ja noch dort im Amt, bald…
Also offiziell ist sie, ist sie nicht mehr
Bundeskanzlerin.
Sie ist schon, man nennt das… sie hat schon
ihre Entlassungsurkunde bekommen, aber sie
ist jetzt noch geschäftsführend im Amt.
Das heißt, sie muss so lange die Geschäfte
führen, bis der Bundestag einen neuen Bundeskanzler
gewählt hat, und das passiert gleich erst.
Und guck mal, Karin schreibt uns heut: "Heute
ist auch der Staatsbesuch von Dänemark.
Unsere Königin und der Kronprinz sind bei
euch zu Besuch.
Vielleicht war es auch die dänische Flagge,
die du gesehen hast."
Sieht die auch so ähnlich aus?
Mein Gott, wir brauchen mehr Diversität bei
den Flaggen, würde ich sagen.
Die dänische Flagge ist ja rot mit einem
weißen Kreuz drin.
War das die vielleicht?
So, guck mal, was… Ich glaube, die Flagge,
die hier zwischen der europäischen und der
deutschen hängt.
Wir sind wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen
zu weit weg davon.
Vielleicht war es ja die.
Okay, wir machen jetzt Flaggenraten, live
mit Manuel.
Janusz, kennst du dich mit Flaggen aus?
Nicht Besonderes, nein.
Oh, jetzt wird es spannend, Leute, hier ist
nämlich alles abgesperrt von der Polizei.
Oh, guck mal, vielleicht hätten wir mal recherchieren
sollen, was hier heute so los ist.
Ja.
Wir sind… Warte mal ganz kurz, ich spreche
mal ganz kurz mit dem Polizisten.
Wir sind von einem YouTube-Kanal und machen
gerade…
Oh, da kannst du mal kurz uns ausblenden.
Gut, dann wird Manuel gleich zurück sein.
Es gibt offensichtlich…
Es sei denn, er wird festgenommen.
Manuel ist jetzt bei der Polizei, wir machen
hier live weiter.
Es gibt tatsächlich heute mehrere Staatsbesuche,
der lettische, die lettische Minist… nee,
der lettische Ministerpräsident ist da, der
portugiesische Premierminister und die dänische
Königin und ihr Mann.
Da ist heute einiges los in Berlin, Janusz,
oder?
Ja, die stehen offensichtlich Schlange zu
Angela.
Die stehen Schlange, um Tschüss zu sagen.
Igor schreibt: "Manuel steckt in Schwierigkeiten."
Das könnte sein, aber ich glaube nicht.
Wir sehen, Manuel regelt das da im Hintergrund,
mal schauen, was passiert.
Ihr könnt ja in der Zwischenzeit uns Fragen
stellen, in den Kommentaren hier an der…
warte mal, an dieser Seite, an dieser Seite
oder hier unten.
Schreibt uns mal einen Kommentar.
Oh, Manuel ist wieder da.
Da ist er.
Ja.
Da rüber?
Hier durch, ja?
Super, vielen Dank!
So, die netten Polizisten haben das mal kurz
geklärt für uns.
Also tatsächlich handelt es sich um den Staatsbesuch
der dänischen Königsfamilie, deswegen ist
hier gerade alles abgesperrt und eigentlich
darf nur die akkreditierte Presse — also
die Journalisten, zu denen ich mich jetzt
noch nicht unbedingt zählen würde — hier
durch, aber wir haben jetzt die offizielle
Erlaubnis bekommen, hier noch mal so durchzuhuschen,
damit wir euch kurz das Brandenburger Tor
zumindest zeigen können und genau.
Das finde ich gut.
Wir dürfen jetzt aber nicht hierbleiben und
auf die Königsfamilie warten, denn dafür
sind wir nicht akkreditiert.
Ja.
Ja, trotzdem.
- In der Zwischenzeit… Es ist aber toll,
dass du das geklärt hast mit der Polizei.
Ja.
Da sind ja auch noch offensichtlich andere
Menschen im Sicherheitsbereich, die da bei
Starbucks sitzen im Hintergrund.
Genau, also wir zeigen jetzt mal ganz kurz,
was hier los ist.
Also hier seht ihr jetzt das Brandenburger
Tor und die Menschen, die also auf das Königshaus
warten.
Und in der Mitte, da steht dann wirklich die
akkreditierte Presse.
Da dürfen wir nun mal eben nicht hin, aber
wir dürfen jetzt hier einmal vorbeilaufen
und ihr seht…
Das sind die Fans von Königin Margrethe.
Das sind die Fans und hier ist immer was los
auf diesem Platz, oder?
Also ich habe das Gefühl, zu jeder Tages-
und Nachtzeit kann man hierhin kommen und
erlebt immer irgendeine Überraschung.
Da sind Dänemark-Fans.
Soll er mit denen nicht sprechen?
Wir freuen uns… Schreibt uns doch mal, wenn
ihr aus Dänemark kommt.
Das ist heute eine Spezial-Episode nur für
euch, liebe Leute.
Manuel, ich finde das total spannend.
Ich finde, du solltest jetzt dabeibleiben.
Frag doch da mal jemanden, wann die kommen.
Vielleicht ist das ja, vielleicht passiert
das ja jetzt.
Ja, das mache ich gerne.
Wir schauen mal, ob ich jemanden finde.
Vielleicht könnt ihr kurz ein paar Fragen
beantworten und dann melde ich mich gleich,
wenn ich jemanden gefunden habe, ja?
Ja, machen wir so, machen wir so.
Gut, dann würde ich sagen, wir nutzen die
Zeit, um ein paar Fragen zu beantworten.
Janusz, bist du bereit?
Ja, gerne.
Und zwar gibt es hier die Frage: "Ist es heute
kalt in Berlin?
Armer Manuel."
Das kann ich persönlich nicht beantworten,
denn ich habe heute das Haus noch nicht verlassen,
aber ich kann bei "Wetter online" sehen, es
ist sieben Grad.
Ja, ich war heute draußen.
Und, Janusz?
War ganz angenehm.
Frisch, aber angenehm.
Sieben Grad ist schon eher kalt.
Dann hat Vivek geschrieben: "Wie spät ist
es in Berlin?"
Bei uns ist es jetzt aktuell 16:11 Uhr, 4:11
Uhr am Nachmittag, und wir haben jetzt gerade
die Winterzeit.
Wir haben die Uhren umgestellt und im Winter
ist es bei uns tatsächlich ab vier Uhr dunkel.
Das ist ein bisschen traurig, oder Janusz?
Ja, aber man muss das immer im Verhältnis
sehen.
Wenn es kalt ist, ich aber gut angezogen bin,
dann ist es trotzdem toll.
Oder wenn es finster draußen ist, aber ich
in meinem Inneren leuchte, dann ist auch die
Balance wieder da.
Das freut mich.
Achmed schreibt: "Was trinkst du, Janusz?"
Ich trinke einen Espresso, einen Cappuccino.
Einen Cappuccino.
Manuel ist wieder da, sehe ich gerade, schau
mal.
Ihr Lieben, ich stehe jetzt hier mit Thomas,
hallo Thomas.
Hallo.
Und Thomas, tatsächlich, wir sind sehr unvorbereitet.
Wir wussten gar nicht, was hier heute los
ist.
Kannst du uns in wenigen Sätzen erklären,
warum du hier stehst und was hier gleich passiert?
Ja, hallo erst mal, ich bin zufällig hier.
Ich wollte nur das Brandenburger Tor sehen
und habe dann von den dänischen Kollegen
erfahren, dass die dänische Königin hier
gleich vorbeikommen soll, und seitdem stehe
ich jetzt hier.
Okay, und wann kommt die Familie hier vorbei?
Sollte schon da sein.
Also, ich gehe mal von aus, das wird gleich
soweit sein, ne?
Fantastisch, ja, vielen Dank!
Viel Spaß dir noch und alles Gute!
Ciao!
Danke schön, Thomas.
Ciao.
Voll viele.
Manuel, du musst jetzt dableiben.
Meint ihr, ich soll hierbleiben?
Ja, auf jeden Fall!
Wir wollen den Staatsbesuch sehen.
Wir wollen…
Und finde… finde jemanden, der etwas Bescheid
weiß von der Familie, von der königlichen
Familie, der uns ein bisschen Hintergrundwissen
erzählen könnte.
Ja, das…
Vielleicht können das ja unsere Zuschauer
aus Dänemark machen.
Schreibt uns doch mal einen Kommentar.
Wie findet ihr das denn, dass Manuel gleich
die dänische Königin sieht?
Ist das etwas, was euch persönlich berührt?
Kenny hat uns gefragt: "Warum verwendet ihr
immer noch Sommer- und Winterzeit?
Ich verstehe es nicht LOL."
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Ich verstehe das auch nicht, aber ich freue
mich immer, weil ich dann immer ein bisschen
überrascht bin, so: Ups!
Und ich habe ein paar Uhren, die automatisch
sich von selbst verstellen, und einige nicht
und die bleiben auch unverstellt.
Ja.
Also es ist tatsächlich so, dass das schon
längst geändert werden sollte.
Die meisten Leute in Europa möchten das ändern,
aber es ist noch nicht geändert worden.
Manuel, sollen wir mal ein paar historische
Bilder zeigen vom Brandenburger Tor?
Das ist ja ein sehr historischer Platz, denn
früher stand dort auch die Berliner Mauer
und dieser Bezirk oder dieser Ort, wo du jetzt
stehst, der war viele, viele Jahre überhaupt
nicht zugänglich für die Allgemeinheit.
Das ist eine sehr gute Idee.
Das ist ja der Pariser Platz hier und der
sieht tatsächlich ganz anders aus, als er
früher aussah.
Und ich bin gespannt, welche Bilder du für
uns vorbereitet hast.
Da hat uns auch jemand gefragt: "Ist Manuel
am Pariser Platz?
Ich möchte auf Google Maps folgen."
Also wenn ihr auf Google Maps folgen möchtet:
Manuel war an der Marshall-Bridge oder Marshall-Brücke
und ist jetzt am Pariser Platz, und er plant,
danach zum Reichstag zu gehen.
Also das alles…
Es geht los, es geht los.
Oh, schau an.
Da kommt die Königsfamilie.
Ja, bravo, wie schön.
Damit hätte ich nicht gerechnet, dass wir
das hier heute machen.
Ist da auch ein Deutscher, ein deutsches Staatsoberhaupt
dabei oder laufen die da alleine?
Ich schaue mal, ich sehe viele Securitys.
Da in der Mitte, da ist doch die Königin
Margrethe, und wer läuft da neben ihr?
Tja, damit kenne ich mich zu wenig aus.
Ich habe zwar mal ein bisschen über die Königshäuser
gelernt, als ich für eine Quizshow lernen
musste, aber mehr weiß ich auch nicht.
So, Königin Margrethe von Dänemark.
Also eigentlich sind ja jetzt unsere dänischen
Fans gefragt.
"Unser nächster König ist zu Besuch da.
Es ist lustig für mich, die dänische Fahne
bei euch zu sehen.
Die dänische Königin und ihr Sohn sind in
Dänemark sehr beliebt", schreibt Karin.
Ja, da ist sie schon wieder vorbei.
Wir sehen jetzt hier gar nicht so viel, denn
es ist ein bisschen verpixelt, Manuel.
Ja, es ist aber, ehrlich gesagt, auch gar
nicht so viel passiert.
Also sie sind jetzt hier vorbeigelaufen, ein
paar vereinzelte Menschen haben geklatscht,
aber jetzt nicht auch so viele.
Ich sehe da hinten ein paar Fahnen im Wind
und das war's.
Also, Königin Margrethe ist 81 und ihr Sohn
Kronprinz Frederik, der nächste König, ist
53.
Das sind jetzt die Sidefacts, die ich herausgefunden
habe.
Sind das interessante Fakten, Manuel?
Sehr.
Sehr interessant.
Und ja, was für ein verrücktes Leben, oder?
Also…
Total.
Ich hoffe, dass du gleich noch Angela Merkel
triffst.
Wollen wir kurz uns die Zeit nehmen, einen
Blick in die Geschichte zu wagen?
Sehr gerne.
Dann würde ich einmal Francisco bitten, uns
das Bild "Mauer Nr. 1" zu zeigen.
Dort sieht man nämlich diesen Bereich jetzt
1961.
Und zwar steht Manuel jetzt links vom Brandenburger
Tor und man sieht dort dieses ganze Areal,
dieser, diese, diesen Ort, wo Manuel jetzt
ist.
Jetzt gibt es da ganz viele Gebäude und damals,
also vor dem Fall der Mauer, vor 1989, war
das alles ein Sperrbezirk.
Das heißt, dass tatsächlich dort die Mauer
stand, man durfte auch nicht in die Nähe
der Mauer gehen, und es gab dort eigentlich
auch fast gar keine Gebäude.
Man sieht dort das Brandenburger Tor ganz
alleine stehen und links und rechts gibt es
keine Gebäude.
Und mittlerweile gibt es dort jetzt zum Beispiel
die Französische Botschaft links, es gibt
die Amerikanische Botschaft, dahinter das
Holocaust-Mahnmal.
Das sind alles Sachen, die früher nicht da
waren.
Und man sieht rechts um das Tor herum die
Mauer.
Du kannst mal das zweite Bild zeigen, Francisco.
Aber warte, ich hätte noch eine Geschichte
zu diesem Bild, und zwar ich bin… Ich weiß
nicht mehr genau, aber irgendwo Ende Achtzigerjahre
bin ich nach Westberlin geflogen, und zwar
absichtlich geflogen, weil ich immer noch
Angst hatte, durch die DDR zu fahren, weil
ich ja ein Flüchtling war.
Und da stand ich vor der Mauer, direkt gegenüber
dem Brandenburger Tor.
Es gab solche Klettergerüste für Touristen,
die durften da raufklettern und so hatten
sie einen sehr guten Ausblick, ja?
Und…
Francisco, kannst du mal das Bild zeigen von
1983?
Da sieht man nämlich den Blick, den Janusz
gerade beschreibt.
Ganz genau, ja.
Das ist die Mauer aus Sicht von Westberlin
in den Achtzigerjahren.
Also man sieht dort die Mauer, dahinter das
Brandenburger Tor.
Dieses Gerüst, wovon du schreibst, sieht
man nicht, aber man sieht dort ein Schild:
"Achtung, Sie verlassen jetzt Westberlin."
Also das war nur eine Warnung, denn man konnte
dort gar nicht über die Mauer oder durch
die Mauer, aber genau.
Zu diesem Ort gehst du jetzt hin, Manuel,
und man sieht dort ja im Boden noch heute,
wo die Mauer stand.
Genau, ist das nicht… Ach, das ist doch
direkt hier vor uns, das ist jetzt ein guter
Zufall, dass hier grad Rot ist.
Hier, diese Steine im Boden, die jetzt hier
direkt vor uns sind, das ist die Linie, wo
früher die Mauer verlief, die ist in ganz
Berlin also so markiert.
Da kann man wirklich einmal komplett auch
eine Fahrradtour machen, wenn man möchte,
dann sieht man einmal, wo die Mauer entlanglief.
Und man sieht wirklich, das war also direkt
hinter dem Brandenburger Tor beziehungsweise
vor dem Brandenburger Tor.
Ja, genau.
Das ist genau, fast genau dieser Blick, den
wir gerade im Foto gesehen haben.
Heute kann man einfach durchgehen, früher
gab es dort die Mauer.
Und dort standest du in den Achtzigerjahren,
Janusz?
Ja, aber auf diesem Gerüst, weil ich habe
auch die Soldaten, die da unten stehen, gesehen
und ja.
Es war malerisch, es war total fremd für
mich, deshalb habe ich noch wenige Assoziationen
gehabt.
Ich wusste im Grunde nicht, was ich da wirklich
sehe, ich wusste nur: Dort, hinter dieser
Mauer, ist Ostberlin und Ostdeutschland und
zu der Zeit noch ein für mich sehr dunkle(s),
bedrohliche(s) Regime und im Grunde eine Geschichte,
die sich kaum hat verstanden (verstehen) lassen
können, ja.
Während Manuel weitergeht, können wir noch
mal einen Blick werfen auf ein Bild von 1984.
Und in diesem Bild sieht man nämlich das
Brandenburger Tor von der anderen Seite.
Das ist die Ostseite, auch in den Achtzigerjahren,
und da sieht man, dass man auch nicht direkt
bis zum Tor gehen kann.
Ganz hinten sieht man die Mauer, ganz klein,
und vorne gibt es eine Besuchersperre.
Also man kann dort sich das Brandenburger
Tor von der Weite angucken.
Sieht ganz nett aus, aber es ist tatsächlich
ein abgesperrter Bereich gewesen.
Manuel, wo gehst du denn jetzt hin?
Wir gehen jetzt hier gerade… Ja, das ist
schon der Tierpark, glaube ich.
Also es gibt ja hier einen sehr, sehr… - Tiergarten.
Tiergarten natürlich, einen sehr großen
Park, der aber "Tiergarten" heißt, und das
ist hier so, sage ich mal, die äußerste
Ecke von diesem doch sehr großen Park.
Und vor uns sehen wir schon das Kanzleramt.
Das sehen wir später noch mal hoffentlich
aus der Nähe, wenn Lorenz und ich uns jetzt
beeilen.
Und rechts von uns ist der Reichstag, also
da versuche ich jetzt mal noch ein bisschen
näher heranzukommen, damit wir uns den noch
mal von vorne anschauen können.
Wow.
Der Tiergarten ist tatsächlich einer der
größten Stadtparks, die es gibt in Europa,
glaube ich, oder vielleicht sogar der Welt.
Ist ein riesiger Park in der Mitte Berlins.
Weißt du, warum der Tiergarten heißt, Manuel?
Nein.
Janusz, erzähl es uns.
Einer der Herrschenden in Berlin hat sich,
hatte keine Lust, zum Jagen irgendwelche längeren
Strecken zu fahren, also hat er sich einen
riesigen Park bauen lassen, hat dort die armen
wilden Tiere verfrachtet und hat sie dort
quasi abgeknallt dann, einfach als Freiheitsspaß.
Oh mein Gott.
Ich hoffe, ich habe nicht irgendwas verdreht,
aber.
Das hast du sehr positiv beschrieben, Janusz.
Ist tatsächlich ein Jagdrevier gewesen, man
konnte dort jagen.
Ob das künstlich angelegt wurde oder tatsächlich
damals schon, also gar nicht erst verbaut
wurde, das weiß ich jetzt nicht, weil…
ja.
Damals war ja Berlin auch noch nicht so dicht
bebaut wie heute und es gab einfach noch verschiedene
Gebiete und eigentlich Städte, die ja jetzt
zusammengewachsen sind.
Oh, was sieht man denn da?
Was ist denn das für ein Kasten da, Manuel?
Ja, diese Kästen, diese Container, das, die
stehen tatsächlich immer hier, obwohl sie
sehr provisorisch aussehen.
Das ist der Eingang für Besucher in den Reichstag,
haben wir auch schon oft empfohlen, auch im
Podcast schon mal als Empfehlung der Woche,
glaube ich.
Wenn man nach Berlin kommt, sollte man unbedingt
dieses Gebäude besuchen, denn es ist sehr
interessant, und diese Kuppel da obendrauf,
die kann man eben auch besteigen, man hat
eine schöne Aussicht auf Berlin.
Und was man aber dann unbedingt vorher machen
muss, ist, im Internet einen Termin zu machen.
Das Ganze ist kostenlos und dann läuft man
hier durch diese Container, wird gecheckt,
muss einmal durch die Sicherheitskontrolle
und dann darf man also hier in den Eingang.
Ja.
Ich lese gerade mal Fragen von unseren Zuschauern.
Da fragt Guacamole: "Macht ihr jetzt jeden
Monat einen Livestream?"
Gute Frage.
Hoffentlich jede Woche.
Nein, einmal im Monat, so ungefähr, ist unser
Ziel.
Immer, wenn Königsbesuch ist.
Richtig, und Donavan schreibt: "Es ist viel
besser jetzt, seitdem Manuel ein bisschen
Hilfe beim Livestream hat."
Oh!
Lorenz, du kannst uns zwar nicht hören, aber
du wirst gelobt von unseren Zuschauern.
Die Kameraarbeit ist toll, besser, als wenn
ich, als ich selbst gefilmt habe.
Okay, dann gibt es noch eine Frage von Andrew.
Er möchte gerne wissen, welche Fußballmannschaft
wir unterstützen.
Da muss ich leider sagen, wir sind alle drei
keine Fußball-Fans.
Da haben wir leider…
Sorry.
Keine besondere…
Präferenz.
Was ist mit deinem… Du warst früher Bayern
München-Fan.
Ich?
Nein, Cari, ich nicht.
Darüber redet man heute nicht mehr.
Aurelie möchte wissen: "Geht Manuel zur Siegessäule?"
Das, also da müssten wir dann gleich ein
bisschen joggen.
Die Siegessäule ist dort drüben, das schaffen
wir aber nicht mehr, weil wir wollen euch
natürlich noch zeigen, wo Angela Merkel im
Moment noch arbeitet.
Das heißt, wir haben uns jetzt auf den Weg
gemacht.
Normalerweise kann man hier über die grüne
Wiese zwischen Reichstag und Bundeskanzleramt
einfach drüber laufen, aber hier scheint
schon wieder irgendein Event zu sein.
Also da steht eine Bühne und hier ist alles
abgesperrt, deswegen laufen wir jetzt außenrum,
aber zur Siegessäule, das schaffen wir nicht
mehr.
Hier ist mal eine sprachliche Frage von Andrea:
"Was ist der Unterschied zwischen Tor und
Tür?"
Ein Tor ist groß und eine Tür ist klein.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Also ein Tor ist, ja, was Großes, ein Gebäude
fast oder ein großer Eingang eigentlich zu
einem Gebäude, und die Tür ist so ein kleines
Ding.
Michael möchte wissen: "Ist das… Ist Reichstag
das Gebäude und Bundestag die Gruppe von
Politiker*innen", oder was ist der Unterschied
zwischen Reichstag und Bundestag?
Sehr gute Frage.
Ja, hat eigentlich Michael selber schon beantwortet:
Reichstag ist das Gebäude, so nennt man heute
noch das Gebäude, und der Bundestag ist im
Prinzip das, ja, das Regierungsorgan, das
in dem Reichstag ist.
Also man könnte sagen, die Gruppe von Politiker*innen,
die im Bundestag sitzen, die sind zusammen
der Bundestag, ja.
Aber ich würde sagen, die Deutschen verwechseln
das auch oft, die sagen: "Ich gehe zum Bundestag",
oder "ich gehe zum Reichstag", die benutzen
das fast…
Braucht ihr Hilfe?
Oh, Manuel möchte Hilfe geben.
- Okay.
Sah so aus, als würden sie was auf der Karte
suchen.
Sehr nett von dir, sehr umsichtig
Freu mich immer, wenn ich Direktionen… wie
sagt man?
Also, Weg… bei der, beim Weg helfen kann,
aber manchmal vertue ich mich auch und dann
ist doof.
Dann hast du doppelt Spaß.
Hier ist eine Frage von Mojtaba, er fragt:
"Ist das Brandenburger Tor in Ostberlin gebaut?"
Dazu kann ich sagen, das Brandenburger Tor
ist schon sehr viel früher gebaut worden,
als es Ost- und Westberlin gab, nämlich 1789
schon.
Also das ist mehr als 100 Jahre vorher, mehr
als 200 Jahre vorher.
Wahnsinn.
Also, das ist schon sehr viel älter, das
Brandenburger Tor, als die Teilung.
Manuel.
Ja.
Wo läufst du jetzt gerade hin?
Erzähl uns ein bisschen was.
Ja, also, wir sehen jetzt die Wiese, von der
ich gerade sprach, und sehen hier den Bundestag
daneben.
Wenn ich mich nicht irre, ist das das Paul-Löbe-Haus,
es ist auf jeden Fall eins der Gebäude, in
denen die Abgeordneten, also diejenigen Politiker,
die dann im Bundestag sitzen, die haben in
diesem Gebäude ihr Büro.
Ihre Mitarbeiter haben dort ihr Büro und
vor uns sieht man jetzt schon das Bundeskanzleramt.
Und all diese Gebäude, es gibt noch ein paar
mehr Gebäude, die quasi zu der Bundesregierung
oder zu diesem Regierungsviertel gehören,
die sind alle unterirdisch verbunden.
Das weiß ich, weil ich auch mal ein Praktikum
bei einem Bundestagsabgeordneten gemacht habe,
und dann durfte ich auch durch diese Tunnel
laufen.
Und tatsächlich ist hier oben nämlich meistens
nicht viel los.
Man sieht ja auch jetzt nicht viele Leute
hier und hier ist aber tatsächlich meistens
reger Betrieb unter der Erde.
Da laufen die Mitarbeiter und die Politiker
dann von Bundestag zu Gebäude eins, zu Gebäude
zwei und so weiter.
Das wusste ich auch nicht.
- Das ist echtes Insiderwissen, Manuel.
Das wussten Janusz und ich auch nicht.
Warst du da mal drin im Tunnel?
Ja, ja, ich bin da durchgelaufen, stand auch
mal mit Frank-Walter Steinmeier im Aufzug
tatsächlich.
Unserem Bundespräsidenten.
Damals war er noch nicht Bundespräsident,
aber genau.
Ich hab hier schon viel erlebt.
Gibt es dort auch Geschäfte und Saunas und…
Nee, nee, das ist überhaupt nicht glamourös.
Das sind so ganz kahle Tunnel, da läuft man
nur schnell durch, also ist nichts, nicht
besonders.
Oh, schade, dachte wie so ein Flughafen unterirdisch.
Guck mal, du beantwortest jetzt perfekt die
Frage von Ge Ha: "Wo wohnt der Kanzler?"
Also im Moment haben wir ja noch eine Kanzlerin
und die wohnt tatsächlich nicht dort, aber
sie arbeitet dort.
Da gibt es aber eine Easy German Episode,
wo wir zu Angela Merkels Wohnung gegangen
sind.
Janusz, welche Episode war das?
Kannst du dich erinnern?
Oh, da frag… guck ich mal eben, das googel
ich mal eben für dich, Manuel.
Natürlich nicht.
Wir standen schon einmal an ihrer Wohnung,
auch damals hatte ich ein nettes Gespräch
mit einem Polizisten, der uns erlaubt hat,
dort zu drehen.
Wir durften dann nur nicht den Polizisten
filmen, also das lief alles sehr fair, und…
Also Frau Dr.
Merkel wohnt, ja, nicht weit von hier, aber
in einer Wohnung.
Und jetzt stehe ich aber tatsächlich vor
ihrem Büro sozusagen beziehungsweise dem
Gebäude, in dem ihr Büro sich befindet und
dann eben auch demnächst der zukünftige
Bundeskanzler, es wird ja wahrscheinlich ein
Mann sein, sitzen wird und arbeiten wird und
dann eben auch Gäste empfangen wird und so
weiter.
Dieses Gebäude, man nennt es auch…
Manuel, sag mal Lorenz, er soll die Kamera
gerade halten.
Lorenz, du sollst mal die Kamera noch etwas
begradigen, soll ich dir ausrichten.
Und dieses Gebäude, das nennt man auch "die
Waschmaschine", das sieht man aber eher, wenn
man von der Seite draufguckt.
Das hätten wir gerade… oder gerade konnte
man das vielleicht schon mal so sehen, dass
an der Seite da so runde, so eine runde Fläche
ist, und deswegen nennt man das auch die Waschmaschine,
weil es ein bisschen aussieht wie die Waschmaschine,
also nicht so schön wie andere Paläste,
Regierungspaläste.
Es ist, das ist schön.
Es fragen sehr viele Leute, wie das Wetter
ist.
Wir haben eben schon gesagt, dass es sieben
Grad ist, aber vielleicht möchten die Menschen
deine Emotionen hören, Manuel.
Wie ist das Wetter?
Wie fühlt es sich an?
Also ehrlich gesagt… Komm, Lorenz, wir gehen
in Richtung Bahnhof, dann können wir gleich
die U-Bahn nach Hause nehmen.
Ehrlich gesagt ist es… Ich bin dick angezogen,
es ist gar nicht so kalt.
Es ist irgendwie sieben Grad, Lorenz hat auch
keine Handschuhe an.
Also ich habe mich sehr gut vorbereitet, weil
ich dachte: "Oh, das wird kalt", aber es ist
eigentlich ein sehr schöner Tag heute noch,
für Berliner Verhältnisse.
Das ist schön.
Dann fragen wir mal, gucken wir mal, was es
hier noch für Fragen gibt.
Und ja, Manuel, ich freue mich total, dass
du so viel Action heute erlebt hast.
Geh doch mal kurz zum Eingang vom Bundeskanzleramt
und schau mal, ob da jemand rauskommt.
Das ist rechts daneben, da ist der offizielle
Eingang.
Hier, ah, das wusste ich zum Beispiel nicht,
okay.
Also das jetzt hier ist der Eingang, da…
Da bin ich schon mal reingegangen.
Guck mal, da sieht man auch dieses… Das
wäre zum Beispiel ein Tor, ein sehr modernes
Tor, da wird jetzt gerade das Gitter hochgefahren.
Genau, da kann man, da fahren die Staatsgäste
rein und raus.
Guck mal, da kommt jetzt gleich ein Auto raus.
Und da vorne in diesem kleinen Gebäude, da
sitzt die Polizei und macht Security-Checks.
Also wenn du da reingehst, musst du wie am
Flughafen deine Sachen abgeben und dich scannen
lassen, und da ist auch einiges los.
Ein weiteres Highlight, Manuel: Die Schweizer
Botschaft ist in Sichtweite.
Da gibt es auch eine Easy German Episode.
Wir verlinken beide diese Videos später in
den, in den, in der Infobox, denn da habe
ich ja mal ein Interview gemacht mit der damaligen
schweizerischen Botschafterin, das war auch
sehr schön.
Ja, es war übrigens Episode 344, als du mit
Janusz durch Berlin gefahren bist.
Ah, stimmt.
Zeig uns doch mal den Eingang vom Bundeskanzleramt,
da ist doch noch so Schild daneben.
Ja, ja, okay, hier, wir wollen noch mal…
Hier sieht man also Bundeskanzleramt, grau
auf grau geschrieben.
Das ist der offizielle Eingang, ja.
Das ist der Eingang, hier steht es und…
Ist auch offiziell, ein silberner Adler auf
dem Stein.
Der Bundesadler, und genau.
Also hier sieht man das so ein bisschen, warum
das Waschmaschine heißt, also da oben dieser
Bogen, das ist quasi der Grund, warum es so
heißt, ja.
Manuel, ich find, du hast eine richtig gute
Strecke heute geschafft.
Toll.
Ja.
Jetzt sollen sie uns noch den Bahnhof zeigen.
Genau, wollte ich grad noch machen.
Also hier, das ist der Berliner Hauptbahnhof,
noch relativ neu.
Wann wurde der erbaut?
Berlin hatte ja lange keinen Hauptbahnhof.
Richtig, und es gab ja… Also das haben wir
vielleicht eben nicht so richtig gesagt, es…
Dadurch, dass Berlin geteilt war, gab es kein
richtiges Zentrum.
Es gab eigentlich mehrere Stadtzentren und
es gab auch mehrere Bahnhöfe, mehrere Flughäfen.
Und als dann Deutschland wiedervereinigt wurde
und Berlin wiedervereinigt wurde, hat man
diesen ganzen Bereich, der früher, wo vorher
nichts war, den hat man ausgebaut zum Regierungsbezirk
und man hat dort einen Hauptbahnhof hingebaut,
ja, in den Neunzigern und Zweitausenderjahren.
Ja.
Und ich erinnere mich, dass kurz, nachdem
er dann endlich fertig war, das war ja auch
ein sehr teures Projekt, dieser gläserne
Bahnhof, ganz tolles, ganz tolle Architektur,
da ist dann, kurz danach hat es ganz doll
geschneit in Berlin und es lag ganz hoch Schnee.
Und vorne, über dem Eingang vom Bahnhof,
das sehen wir jetzt gleich, wenn dieser Baum
hier weg ist, da ist so ein Vordach, also
so ein Dach, was über den Eingang drüber
geht, und das ist am Anfang einmal eingekracht.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr euch da noch dran
erinnern könnt.
Oh, nee, tatsächlich nicht.
Das war… ja.
Manuel, wir beantworten noch zwei Fragen,
würde ich sagen, und zwar einmal ist das
die von Michael: "Ist Olaf Scholz schon zum
Kanzler gewählt worden?"
Ja, Cari, das kannst du gut beantworten, da
hast du letztens im Podcast schon drüber
gesprochen.
Er ist noch nicht gewählt worden, denn die
Koalitionsverhandlungen laufen noch.
Das heißt, die Regierung muss sich erst formieren
und dann wählen sie den Kanzler.
Und dann ist hier jemand, der schreibt: "Janusz,
du solltest auch mal reden."
Oh ja, aber ich genieße heute meine Stellung
als Beobachter, ja.
Janusz, du kannst gleich noch mal zusammenfassen:
Wie hat Manuel das bisher gemacht, seinen
Job als rasender Reporter in Berlin?
Ja, ganz toll.
Ich wäre sowieso dafür, dass wir das jede
Woche machen, jeden Mittwoch einfach, und
wir nennen das "Mittwochsgänge durch Berlin",
aber…
Mittwochsgang.
Gänge.
Spaziergänge durch Berlin.
Ich find's perfekt, es ist ein wunderschöner
Hintergrund jetzt.
Guck mal, da ist der Himmel so richtig lila,
und das ist doch ein schönes Abschlussbild,
Manuel im Sonnenuntergang.
Wir haben dich beobachtet, du hast einen Staatsbesuch
gesehen, du warst am Hauptstadtstudio von
der ARD, du warst am Brandenburger Tor, du
warst an, beim Amtssitz von Angela Merkel.
Was will man mehr, Manuel?
Was will man mehr?
Das Einzige, was ich mir noch wünsche, ist,
dass ihr, liebe Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer,
ein Mitglied werdet von Easy German, damit
wir Janusz' Traum erfüllen können und jede
Woche so was Verrücktes hier machen können.
Und ansonsten hat es mir heute auch sehr viel
Spaß gemacht tatsächlich.
Das war die perfekte Zusammenfassung, Manuel.
Das ist tatsächlich etwas, wo wir euch einladen.
Ihr könnt ein Mitglied werden von Easy German,
patreon.com/easygerman ist die Website.
Das ist ein Mitgliederservice oder ein Zahlungsservice,
den wir benutzen, und darüber könnt ihr
ein Mitglied werden, für einen Monat, für
zwei Monate, vielleicht auch für drei Jahre.
Es gibt Leute, die sind schon sehr lange dabei.
Und als Mitglied könnt ihr uns unterstützen
einmal, also, wir finanzieren unser Projekt
durch diese Mitgliedschaften, denn wie ihr
wisst, sind ja unsere Videos und unsere Podcast-Episoden
umsonst, für alle zugänglich.
Aber ihr bekommt auch etwas als Mitglied,
und zwar, Manuel?
Und zwar bekommt ihr zu unseren Videos interaktive
Übungen, so Lückentexte und Vokabellisten,
das heißt, ihr könnt dann wirklich mit dem
Video auch etwas lernen.
Und dann gibt es noch verschiedene andere
Angebote, da seht ihr so verschiedene Levels
zu unserem Podcast und auch eine Community
Membership, wo ihr täglich mit uns chatten
könnt, also, schaut euch das einfach mal
an.
Es war toll mit euch.
Janusz, nächstes Mal schicken wir dich wieder
auf die Straße.
Wo fährst du hin?
Oh, gerne.
Darf ich mir auch den, die Strecke aussuchen?
Natürlich.
- Absolut.
Hast du schon eine Idee?
Ich würde gerne durch den Flohmarkt laufen.
Das ist eine tolle Idee.
Das ist eine sehr schöne Idee.
Nächstes Mal sind wir wahrscheinlich erst
mal auf dem Weihnachtsmarkt.
Das war eine Idee, die wir hatten.
Stimmt.
Und da werden wir uns dann melden.
Ja, liebe Leute, es war schön mit euch.
Danke, dass ihr alle zugesehen habt.
Danke an Lorenz hinter der Kamera, danke an
Francisco hinter den Kulissen hier als Regisseur,
kann man sagen.
Und danke auch an Erik, der sich um die Community
gekümmert hat.
War schön mit euch allen und ich freue mich
schon auf den nächsten Livestream, und dann
vielleicht mit dem amerikanischen Präsidenten,
Manuel, wer weiß?
Zum Beispiel, who knows?
Bis bald!
Bis bald, tschüss!
Ciao.